Nikki Haley has served as the 116th
governor of South Carolina she has
served as the 29th U.S ambassador to the
United Nations now she is seeking the
presidency
and after Donald Trump Nikki Haley is
the first declared Republican candidate
for the 2024 presidential nomination
and now she is sitting down with me to
discuss her campaign
[Music]
the last time I saw Nikki Haley she was
teaching me how to be a un ambassador
I am still not the UN Ambassador but she
is now running for president Nikki thank
you so much thank you and you almost had
the veto down but not quite not my hand
yeah it doesn't I'll keep working on it
yeah maybe in a Haley Administration I'm
just putting it out there I I'll keep
recording who knows so Nikki
congratulations and entering into the
race
I've got a list of 10 questions okay
answer them however you like I they're
from a smattering across policy
philosophy history first question real
Hardball
who's your favorite President
I have two Lincoln and Reagan Lincoln
and Reagan good choices
what book has most influenced the way
that you view politics
the most recent book because I I feel
like
I've read but the most recent book
really was JD Vance's book I just
related to it so much and I because I
grew up very similar in the way that you
know you lived with people who didn't
know what we didn't have
and to not forget their voices and to
understand that they matter is really
important you know because in rural
South Carolina you know you've got
schools that are challenging and you've
got companies don't come always where
they need to and that's why when I was
governor I focused so much on every
single part of South Carolina and I
think we need to focus on every single
part of the country but you have to look
at the cultures you've got to look at
the people you've got to look at you
know what they do and how they live and
I thought that JD did an amazing job of
really describing who they are what they
care about and what we need to do as a
country to make sure that we let them
know we've got solutions that lift up
everybody well speaking of reaching out
to people that one does not typically
reach out to you have had a lot of
crossover appeal more so than many of
the candidates who have been talked
about as as potential nominees
what is one time that you have reached
across the aisle successfully or
unsuccessfully and what is one issue on
which you most likely would not be able
to reach across the aisle the hardest
issue I think of having to deal with
Reaching Across the aisle was after we
had the shooting at mother Emanuel
Church and you had a white supremacist
come in to a church it was the first
time we had had a a shooting in a place
of worship and these 12 people did what
so many South Carolinians do on a
Wednesday night they went to Bible study
but somebody else showed up he didn't
look like them he didn't sound like them
he didn't act like them and when they
bowed their prayers their heads in that
last prayer he began to shoot
and South Carolina was devastated
three days later he showed you know he
had his Manifesto out and he was showing
the Confederate flag
and this was on the heels of Ferguson
and you were watching riots on TV you're
watching that and I knew that I had to
somehow protect the state and really
pushing for the flag to come down was
something that you had to be really
respectful about because half of South
Carolinians saw the flag as Heritage and
service the other half saw it as slavery
and hate my job wasn't to judge either
side my job was to get them to see the
best of themselves and go in a different
direction it took two-thirds of the
house and two-thirds of the Senate but
what we were able to do is tap into the
best part of people and say let's put
this Confederate flag instead of the
front of the state house where it's a
living breathing symbol let's put it in
a museum where it belongs and then move
on as South Carolinians and South
Carolinians did that the next push they
of course were like what about monuments
what about street signs and I was like
we're not doing that and I strong-armed
and said we will never do that because
you can't arrange race history you can
add to history so instead they're adding
a monument for the mother Emanuel
victims they built a African-American
Museum and so that was one that was
really not just hard but emotional for
the people of South Carolina and it was
you know part of who they were and so
getting them to see there's a better
place we could go but you don't have to
hate each other to do it was really
important now what would be one issue
because obviously you
successfully we're able to affect that
policy
what would be one issue where you think
I probably couldn't work with the other
side
if there is one I mean the one thing I I
would love to do is term limits because
I don't think that that's an issue for
Republicans Or democrats I think that's
an issue for Americans I mean look at DC
look at how long everybody's been there
and so do I think Congress will ever
pass a term limit spell on their own no
but what we have to do is you couldn't
work with either side that's exactly
right but what we have to do is get the
American people to say when every single
Congressman decides to run are you for
term limits and make them do it at that
moment and when America goes and puts
them to where they have to answer and
they have to sign a pledge and they have
to follow through with it that's how I
think we're going to get it but I think
that's going to be incredibly tough
because they don't want to leave the
power of it all and that's a Republican
or a Democrat thing right neither side
has any interest in that at least of the
office holders yes according to the
polls the top issue for everybody is the
economy and not just the economy but
cost of living which is through the roof
right now but it's a very thorny issue
because any policy that you can
undertake is going to have consequences
that you don't want to see so how does
President Haley deal with record high
inflation without harming employment
very much like what we had to do in
South Carolina you know when I took on
as Governor we had double-digit
unemployment and you know everything had
kind of Fallen to the Wayside and I had
to build the state back up what we need
to do in America is first stop the
spending binge that's happening in D.C I
mean it's ridiculous how much they're
spending and it's Republicans and
Democrats why did they open up earmarks
why are we spending 12 million on a
baseball stadium in New York or 15
million for New Jersey to get the World
Cup or six and a half million for golf
courses in Colorado stop the spending
secondly balance a budget I did it as
governor in South Carolina many
Governors do it why is it that D.C
doesn't do it we should put we should
really push to balance a budget then
look at 15 percent of our budget is
interest well stop borrowing we have to
we're now borrowing money just to make
our interest payments we need to
actually focus on pushing the debt down
because our kids are never going to
forgive us for this but the big sting of
what we're going to have to do is look
at the supply chain and understand that
we've got to start building things in
America again and that means when we
build things in America that's what's
going to help with inflation and then
for all the people who say we can't talk
about entitlement reform guess what you
got to talk about entitlement reform but
that means you don't have to take away
things that have been promised to people
but you do have to look at that new
group coming in and say you're going to
have to play by different roles I had
that situation in South Carolina with
pensions we made sure that those that
were promised got but we told the new
ones coming in it's a different game for
you and they know they're not going to
get it anyway and so we've got to start
doing something so it's those hard
decisions I'm not a lawyer I'm an
accountant so it's those decisions that
are tough but we shouldn't pass any
bills that do anything that raise the
spending level that we have every bill
has to work towards Bringing Down the
debt when we do that and commit to that
then it'll be a different day in America
that would be another issue where you're
taking on both sides because obviously
the Democrats have no interest in
entitlement reform and then the house
Speaker Kevin McCarthy just came out and
said entitlement reform Dead on Arrival
president Haley says we're good we're
going to run out in 2028. like we have
to do it but I don't think we have to
raise taxes to do it I think you just
have to go back and look at the system
and say let's try something new on
another big issue that people are
focused on immigration
assuming that you want to put an end to
Illegal immigration which most
reasonable people do
what do you do about the people already
here do you put them on a path to
citizenship do you not put them on a
path to citizenship and furthermore when
it comes to Legal immigration do you
restrict it do you expand it or do you
keep it about the same so I am the
daughter of legal immigrants they came
here they put in the time they put in
the price they are offended by what's
happening on the board the very first
thing is we have to secure the Border we
have to stop Catch and Release we have
to go back to romaina Mexico but more
than that we have to understand we're a
country of laws the second you stop
being a country of laws you give up
everything this country was founded on
and we right now are watching Biden give
more money to illegal immigrants and
we're seeing given to Citizens these
days so I think we have to acknowledge
that we have an immigration problem when
it comes to immigration reform and DACA
everybody's quick to want to talk about
DACA we don't talk about DACA until they
do immigration reform Congress loves to
complain about it they need to get in a
room and do it and it's time for a
change we need more processors we need
to look at who's coming in but more than
that we should look at what will make
our country better do it on Merit do it
based on the talent we need not just
bringing people in and do what I did in
South Carolina across the country we
passed an Arizona style e-verify program
that said no business could hire anyone
that was in this country illegally they
all left South Carolina because they
couldn't get a job let's have them all
leave America because they can't get a
job we've got to start making sure that
we focus on the Americans that live here
and not the illegals that are coming in
feeding off the hospitals feeding off
our schools feeding off the economy and
giving law enforcement more issues so we
have to do that but we do have to have
immigration reform but I think it should
absolutely be on Merit now what about
legal immigration this is one area that
a lot of people don't talk about out
according to whichever polls one looks
at a lot of Americans including many
Democrats want to reduce the legal
number a number of legal immigrants
rather who come into the country
everywhere would you
would you touch that would you say let's
only focus on illegal immigration that's
when you have to focus on your economy
what I did in South Carolina is I knew
what our manufacturers needed I knew
what our small businesses needed I knew
what our Farmers needed look and see
what they have look and see what
Americans can fill then you look at
immigration you should only be bringing
in what you need not what you have I
think the problem for too long has been
they're looking at numbers well the
numbers don't work instead do it on
Merit do it based on what will make a
our America better and look at the
things that we're doing you've got kids
that come in from overseas we train them
in our colleges and then we turn around
and send them home why are we doing that
just focus on educating the ones you
need and then keep them if that's the
talent that you have to have rather than
looking at a firm number just say okay
what what do the companies need to fill
the jobs and we're not going to bring in
more than we need to fill those jobs but
no because there are times where if
we've got plenty then you can slow that
down if there's times that may have
factors say we need this Talent we need
this skill you can pick it back up now
among the presidential field one expects
lots of Governors and you've been a
governor one expects lots of senators
very few people in the presidential
field will have foreign policy
experience you do happen to have foreign
policy experience
tomorrow China invades Taiwan what does
President Haley do well if we're smart
China doesn't invade Taiwan because we
have to focus on how we're handling
Ukraine it's a big issue you know many
people think this is about Ukraine it's
bigger than Ukraine it's about freedom
and that's a war we have to win we don't
have to put more money in it we don't
have to put troops on the ground but we
do need to get with our allies and send
equipment and ammunition that they need
to win if Biden would have done this
sooner
if you look back this actually was with
Obama when he went into Crimea he didn't
do anything it gave Putin the green
light to say
they don't have the will to do this then
they go and invade Ukraine and Biden was
slow to the take if we would have been
strong and firm in the beginning it
would have made a big difference but
look at what the ukrainians did
here these men went to the front lines
to fight for their freedom and their
country they put their women and
children off to the side the women said
no that's not going to happen they made
Molotov cocktails and they have gone
when they gave them five days to save
their country look at them now they are
gaining ground back and you know how far
Putin has fallen when they're getting
drones from Iran and missiles from North
Korea they've raised the draft age to
65. they've lost thousands of soldiers
so Putin knows that there's not a place
to go but the lesson in all of this is
when a dictator says they're going to do
something we need to believe it
president XI said he was going to take
Hong Kong we watched it Putin said he
was going to take Ukraine he's done that
she has said Taiwan is next we better
believe him Putin has said Poland and
the baltics are next if Ukraine loses
and Russia moves in we're looking at a
full-on World War we're trying to
prevent War at this point we've got to
prevent War we don't want China moving
into Taiwan so the best thing is make
sure Taiwan is strong make sure we're
strong with Ukraine and we finish this
and then we'll tell every enemy not to
go further if Ukraine loses then we're
in a world of hurt
very often these problems Compound on
themselves Vladimir zielinski agreed
with everything you just said he said
had
Joe Biden not taken the sanctions off of
Russia Russia would not have invaded had
Joe Biden not actually said if Russia
takes on a minor incursion into Ukraine
we won't do very much Russia very likely
would not have invaded so you see that
weakness from the previous
administration creating problems
for whoever the next but let's also
remember Russia never would have invaded
if we wouldn't have had the debacle in
Afghanistan right the idea that we left
Bagram Air Force Base in the middle of
the night without telling our allies who
stood shoulder to shoulder with us for
decades because we asked them to be
there think about what that told our
friends more importantly think about
what that told Putin and she right they
knew they'd never see another weak
president like this but what if well
this very likely would be the case you
inherit an America which had this
debacle in Afghanistan which is
projecting weakness around the world
which has fumbled the Ukraine war from
before it was a war and so you get in
there through no fault of your own
America is looking very very weak and
chairman she to whatever degree he wants
is aggressing into Taiwan
how do you deter further aggression so
first a strong military doesn't start or
is a strong military prevents Wars we
have to strengthen our military we've
got to modernize it we've got to let
China know we're on to them look at how
they have the largest naval fleet in the
world they have more air defense systems
we do and they're modernizing their
military they're stealing our
intellectual property no one is doing
anything about it they're committing
genocide everybody's solid because
they're too scared to deal with China
but president XI started a commission
that said any company that does business
in China has to cooperate with the
Chinese military think about our tech
companies think about our financial data
think about our health care data think
about our kids lifestyle data and know
that the Chinese military has it but
what is America doing we're not
strengthening our military instead we're
making them take gender pronoun classes
I know that my husband's a combat
veteran we're not doing anything about
the intellectual property we should go
tell our universities you either take
Chinese money or you take American money
you don't get both and make them decide
we should not be allowing China to buy
380 000 Acres of American soil that we
know they're putting next to they're
buying next to military installations
recently at Grand Forks Air Force Base
that's where our most sensitive drone
technology is it's ludicrous to do that
we have yet to hold them accountable for
covet which think they closed their
borders to people coming in and they
opened their borders to people going out
and of all the drug issues we have who's
saying anything to China about the fact
that the fentanyl is coming from them
and they know exactly what they're doing
so when we do that and when we start to
be strong it makes a difference but we
are giving 46 billion dollars in Aid to
countries and most of them hate us why
are we giving money to China for the
environment why are we giving money to
Pakistan why are we giving money to
communist Cuba why are we giving money
to Zimbabwe the most anti-American
African country there is we have to stop
giving money to countries that hate
America and when we we start to say this
is different we're going to be strong
we'll have the backs of our allies and
for those that even try and mess with us
we're going to take names that's when
life changes that's when we have to tell
those countries what we expect of them
instead of being reactionary it's very
interesting you say that because you
have a reputation whether this is
deserved or not as more interventionist
when it comes to foreign policy and here
you are talking about cutting forward
I'm the wife of a milli I'm a military
wife do you think I want my husband to
go to war it's the total opposite what I
want is our military to be so strong
nobody wants to touch it and that's
where we have to go everything we do
should always be about preventing War we
should never but you don't prevent War
by cowering you don't prevent War by
looking weak you don't prevent War by
being scared of the enemy you prevent
War by being strong and letting them
know what you expect and you tell them
not to doubt you that's what we did at
the United Nations I told countries what
America was for and what America was in
I didn't care if they didn't like me but
I wanted them to respect America that's
what we have to do well speaking of
China and speaking of the best defense
sometimes being a good offense which
sounds like what you're describing
when it comes to trade there's been a
big shift in the way that Republicans
have talked about trade for the early
part of the Republican party it was a
more protectionist party in fact it was
founded in many ways on tariffs for much
of recent Republican history it's been
the free trade party and you saw that
especially during the Reagan Era and
after the Reagan Era
recently it's turned back a little bit
more toward a protectionist party or I'm
just not quite sure it's in flux so
president Haley looking at trade
does she make trade Freer more
protectionist or
about the same you look at National
Security First
when covid came they told us to put on
masks they were made in China they told
us to take Cova tests they were made in
China if you go and get your medicines
guess what they're made in China we have
to go and start looking at our national
security I don't care if Americans buy
T-shirts and light bulbs from China any
more than I care if China buys
agricultural products from our Farmers
but I don't want us to be dependent on
an enemy for things that Americans need
for security that's the lens you want to
look at yes of course we want free trade
but when it comes to an enemy don't ever
be dependent on anyone else and that's
why we need to build more things in
America and what we can't build in
America go to our allies go to India go
to Australia go to Japan go to Israel
those are the ones we need to be going
to we shouldn't be dependent on China so
yes you want free trade but National
Security comes above all else it's about
protecting Americans and making sure
you're doing things that are smart and
we haven't done things that were smart
in a long time when it comes to our
foreign adversaries in order to
encourage manufacturing America would
you do that through say protective
tariffs would you do that through
deregulation to encourage companies
through the market to come back to
America or some accommodations I would
do what I did in South Carolina we had
double digit unemployment all our jobs
had gone to were in textiles and they
all went overseas and we didn't have
anything and so I started recruiting
foreign direct investment because I
wanted to make things in America again
we went to all of our agencies and we
said we're if you're costing a person or
a business time you're costing them
money and that's no longer acceptable we
pull back regulations we made sure that
things were free-flowing we cut all the
red tape by the time I left we were
building planes with Boeing more BMWs
than any place in the world we brought
in Mercedes-Benz Volvo five
International Tire companies and they
were referring to us as the Beast of the
southeast and we had the lowest
unemployment we had had in 15 years the
key was we didn't just bring the
companies we retrained South Carolinians
to do those jobs we made sure that it
was helping the people that I was
serving first and I think that's what we
have to look at when we look at America
you want business we want to be able to
build things we want to be able to have
trade but do trade with friends don't do
trade with enemies and that's the
biggest look at the Europeans they
learned that the hard way
speaking of protecting Americans on on
the social front beyond the economic
questions even Beyond National Security
the social fabric has frayed you're
seeing marriage rates plummet to
all-time lows you were seeing birth
rates plummet to all-time lows you're
seeing abortion continue to remain high
even after the adopt's decision
the family is in trouble what would the
Haley Administration do to help to
restore the American family stop paying
them to not get married I mean people
right now you get more money if you're
single so you'll see two singles and
they'll have a baby but it on their
taxes and in terms of getting Aid it's
better off for them not to get married
we need to reward the family unit so
first of all get all the bureaucrats out
of education and quit trying to teach
anything to our kids because parents
need to decide it you know I look at
honestly the critical race theory that
they did think about if a five-year-old
girl goes into school if she's white
you're telling her she's bad if she's
brown or black you're telling her she's
never going to be good enough and she's
always going to be a victim I mean it's
terrible and then you've got the the
don't say gay bill that everybody was up
in arms about and basically it said
don't talk about gender before third
grade I don't think that went far enough
when I was in school you didn't have sex
ed until seventh grade and even then you
had to have your parents sign a
permission slip and my dad wouldn't sign
it so I was the uncool kid in the
classroom next door great dad that's
stuff that needs to be handled at home
we need to go back to Faith Family and
community and allow those things to
happen we need to go back to every
school saying the Pledge of Allegiance
and remembering what it means to be
patriotic we need to allow all the
things that government wants to be
involved in we need to remember that
government was intended to secure the
rights and freedoms of the people it was
never meant to be all things to all
people when we pull that out of the
lives of people and allow them to be
free and when we reward a family unit
that's when good things happen you know
I think we and you also have to look at
those that have challenges when I was in
South Carolina we had so many people on
welfare and what I did was I went to the
businesses that needed workers and I
said I will give you this person I will
pay for them for X weeks if you train
them and at the end of that you decide
whether you want to keep them we moved
over 20 000 people off of welfare to
work because when those people saw what
it meant to have a job when they felt
that dignity when they felt that
responsibility and when the business
owner trained them and put the time and
effort it was a win-win we've got to
start doing more things like that that's
hugely important so so you're saying
even before thinking about things that
the government can do proactively to
encourage families
first stop the bleeding stop doing I
don't want government involved in I
don't want government involved in our
families I think that's the problem is
you've got government in schools trying
to teach kids about what a family should
be you've got government welfare going
to people telling them they shouldn't
get married you've got things like that
that are making people more dependent on
government I actually want less of that
that's when we pull government back I
think we could start to heal the family
unit and start to go back to community
and family and churches and that's where
it should be
one threat to the family would be the
criminals that are marauding all over
the streets there are some people in the
country who say that we have an over
incarceration problem and we need to
actually arrest fewer criminals and get
rid of certain prisons others look
around they say murder rates have spiked
to recent highs in cities around the
country actually maybe we have an under
incarceration problem because there are
so many criminals out there
what does the Haley Administration and
the Haley justice department do about
crime you go deeper than that and it
again it's what I did as governor of
South Carolina we went first of all Law
and Order matters you need to have the
backs of police and they have to enforce
laws and District Attorneys have to
prosecute them so we need to make sure
that we're doing that but the second
thing is I took time to go into our
presence and figure out how they were
getting in there and what was happening
when they got out we went we started
teaching them financial planning we
taught them Family Planning we offered
them faith-based classes if they wanted
them and then I took equipment from our
businesses put it behind the fence we
trained our inmates so that now in South
Carolina when someone leaves the fence
they've got a job to go to the next day
we have the lowest recidivism rate in
the country now we did that by making
sure they never go back in So enforce
the laws let the police do their jobs
give them the penalties they get a
punishment you do the crime you got to
pay the time but let's train them on
something else so that when they leave
the first thing is not to go out there
and sell drugs again not to go out there
and commit another crime let's actually
give them a job so that they can get to
work and start rehabilitating who they
are themselves
final question
patriotism is a what would seem to be an
all-time low and not just on the left
the left for a long time has been
unpatriotic I think and says has said
that the country is evil and oppressive
and has a terrible history and we
shouldn't like it
many on the right now are beginning to
believe that America is a woke Empire
that we're spreading all sorts of crazy
values and transgenderism and whatever
all around the world and that we've lost
our way and it's very difficult even for
a conservative who used to bleed red
white and blue to feel pride and and
satisfaction in the country right now
how would president Haley restore
patriotic love of country on both the
left and the right and that's why I'm
doing this that that is why I'm doing
this because when my parents came here
they came to a country that was
confident and growing and bright and
full of opportunities and now I look at
a country that's covered in National
self-loathing where people are saying
we're bad or we're woke or we're racist
or all these other things we have to go
back and restore patriotism we have to
go back and have love of country and our
kids need to know that America deserves
their love and when we go and do that
again that's when I think we'll get back
on track you have to have kids saying
the Pledge of Allegiance in school every
day we have to go remind people that
every individual needs to bring back the
spirit of what our national purpose is
and you look as a military wife I can
tell you like you see that sacrifice and
you see the courage that our military
men and women go to defend it we have to
go back and understand we're the best
country in the world we're the freest
country in the world but we won't always
be like that if we don't love her if we
don't really put in the time to get her
back to where she needs to be we look so
distracted right now Michael and when we
when America is distracted the world is
less safe when we start to focus again
on getting people to work fixing our
economy teaching our kids the right
education we need to be teaching them
and start being strong again on the
world stage that patriotism will come in
but you have to bring out the best of
people that's what's been lacking we're
not bringing out the best of people
we're bringing out the worst in people
we have to go back to remind them love
of country and that happens when they
see production when they see people
moving when they see people working and
when they see people living with a good
quality of life again I really like that
word distracted it's it's a really
precise way to describe what's going on
in fact I've heard sin described as not
just the rejection of God and Evil in
itself but
it's just a distraction distraction so
one issue that has crept up is what
religion has to do with all of this you
know John Adams says the country is
built for a moral and religious people
and it's not fit for anybody else
religion has completely declined in the
country people don't really know what
they believe at all anymore you
mentioned the spirit of America
what's the spirit look like I mean the
spirit of America is built on faith
family and Community that's always been
the spirit of America and so you know I
think they say that that less people are
going to church than ever before
if you combine all of these things it
all adds up you know we've got to go
back to where yes we see each other as
neighbors we understand we're one
American family we want our children to
live better lives than we live we've got
to go back to what the men and women who
sacrifice their lives fought for they
fought for that they fought for us to
have a an America that was patriotic and
loved country and didn't fall into
socialism and didn't fall into National
self-loathing we owe it to them to go
back and find our purpose in America and
I think that's hugely important and I
think what we're seeing is with all
these distractions people are finding
reasons to hate each other but what we
have to remember too is
Republicans have lost the last seven out
of eight popular votes for President we
have to look at the mirror means that
we're doing something wrong we should
want to win a majority of Americans
because our policies are right our
Solutions are right we focus on lifting
up everybody not just a select few but
look at how we've been acting we lost
the midterms we didn't lose it because
of one person we lost it because when
you had Independence and those that
weren't sure where they wanted to vote
they saw Republicans hitting each other
and hitting Democrats they didn't want
to be part of that chaos
let's remind them that Republicans are
patriotic we're freedom-loving people
that believe in that our best days are
ahead of us but we have to get back to
that and we should do it by addition we
need Hispanics we need the Jewish
Community we need Asians we need
African-Americans we need women
I know we can do it because I did it in
South Carolina you don't go to them by
saying you should be with us you go to
them by saying what do you care about
and guess what they all care about their
kids education they all want school
choice because they want to be able as
parents to be able to decide where to
send their kids to school they all care
about making sure their kids have
opportunities they didn't have they all
want a safe America that's strong abroad
when you have those conversations and
you communicate it that way people will
come if you're tired of losing that's
why I'm telling Americans to stand with
me America deserves better families
deserve better than how we're living
today I don't want my children to grow
up like this I mean I see my daughter
and how hard it is for her and her
fiance to buy a home I see my son having
to go and take tests and write things
that he doesn't believe in just to get
an a right I don't want that for my
children but I don't want that for
anybody's children and I think we owe it
to everybody to all invest and say we're
going to be part of the solution we're
not going to whine and complain about it
anymore
Ambassador Haley thank you for making
the time fun we'll see you out on the
campaign Trail thank you I appreciate it